[Applaudissements]
les mecs que vous êtes là djamel menad
djamel qui m'appelle sur mon portable
soit accolé ont bien voulu mais à l'eau
je n'ai pas sur war halo djamel je te
jure tu veux ma pays contraints
d'appeler l'un c'est pas vrai alors il y
aura des crottes de mon but qui me le
rende karatantcheva lie à jamel qui
m'appelle je jure que je n'ai perdu tout
à l'heure à merde alors voilà incroyable
si vous avez le portable de djamel
n'essayez pas de m'appeler je m'en fous
je t'ai l'oeuf et le gars me rappelle
non mais sans déconner à la halo c'est
qui mais vous êtes sûr qu'il ait pas
dans votre poche mais nos cousins ce
jugement les inquiétudes très bien on va
parler de miss france